Ba Ba Ba
It is time for me to play the levels
that you guys have made in ASS
the greatest game of all time
link in Bio
Let's see what you guys came up with
"Did you laugh, or did--" *laughs*
god there's so many *chuckles*
PewDieRoller 99.99% possible
I'll be the judge of
wait possible?
You were supposed to make them 99.9% impos'd
oh god
Whoa
you see that
That was eas--
that was so easy
Wow
disappointed okay
I'm gonna leave a
mini level. I'll give it a like
"Did you laugh, or did you lose?"
#001
uh okay
Great
I guess I lost
oh look I have this
no what the f--
What
There it is
hell yeah bab--
*higher pitched* hell yeah man
Oh
Easy
Oh Wow
What?
screw this
you can't tell me how to live my life
Oh
I'm really impressed like
you guys using all the features in delete
why do I explode?
Come on
oh ye--
what?!
It's fine I can make it
I can make it
It's fine
ish fine Mr. Puffy
That's my checkpoint
hell yeah man
look at that cheating
oh my god
did you have to place it so far away
eeeasy!
omae wa
mou shindeiru
eeeasy
Pretty well designed
and you know
Oh God
come on
Yes
Ohhh!
kay?
what?
I laughed
and I lost
Well done
me!
good job
nice match Clowch
appreciate it.
That's dope
Indiana Jones
okay
Oh wow
okay great
great start
off to a fantastic
Oh look! It's...
*laughs*
No oh oh
oh that's cool man
you guys are so creative
I 'm so proud of you
Oh wow,
I'm so good at this
where's the giant boulder though?
Are you kidding me?
What just happened
Oh
Oh! I can grab the wheels
Oh my god, that's so cute!
Yes! hahaha
Oh!
Come on little puffer!
Hell yeah!
Oh my God he's so fast
Yes
Go forth little puffer
Oh my god puffer
Gaaaahhh
Ah that's awesome
no no no
I'm so I'm so impressed actually
And I was being sassy and shit before
but this is such a creative level, and it's only one
oh God
And it's only one of the first
That was so fun
Clow--Oh it was Clowch again
god damn.
Uh we have "Pewdiepie your favorite thing ever"
okay
What is my favorite thing ever?
Oh ba--barrels!
hey, I did it
Great job
great job Saladin
What a great level
Wow was praising you guys a minute ago
"Loops N' more V1.2."
Okay?
What is happening?
nemas problemas as we say in Sweden
which means good fortune
happens to those who wait
oh god
This car is too good, man.
Mm. Look at that
Oh
Oh wow look I did the loop
you're welcome.
Oh god.
Oh god
He--Hey! Oh!
Oh whoa!
what is happening?
NOOOOOOO
ahahahaha
Hey I know a shortcut
shortcut, oh god
it's fine.
I may be on fire
*boof*
never mind I died
Wait! I'm sushi!
I'm sushi!
Come on you can do it sushi!
Nawwww
Sushi!
Sushi nawww
Ah
dammit
Game of the Year
you can play as sushi
Come on
come on
I missed it didn't--
no I did it
oh okay
cool
What is this vehicle?
Oh it's the flame one
Get that speed mr. Puffer
Get that
speeeeed
ahhhhh
Come on come on come on come on
What the heck?!
Why do I explode?!
Oh, if you charge it all the way you explode
I didn't--
Dammit
Whoo
that's what I'm talking about
Go puffer girl
"Hell you mean?"
ssssssss
speed
Oh
Oh come on
you pointed down
asshole
I'm just gonna keep going
screw you
I'm pretty sure I missed something import--
Oh great
ow
I'm fine.
Don't worry about it.
Don't worry
Just don't worry
OH
shortcut
Oh God Oh
Nailed it
Nailing it
Killing it.
Killing it man
You're a living legend Mr. Puffer
Look at that
I--that's I did that on purpose
don't worry guys
these loops are really cool
Here we go
another great level
it took me four minutes
Jesus Buffin Muffin well done on making a great level
"Barrels of Fun" everybody
I wonder what's gonna happen
I'm not having barrels of fun
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I made it
what the hell
hahaha
Screw you
I had given up
go forth Mr. Puff
You can do it (x1)
You can do it (x2)
You can do it (x3)
easy (x1)
easy (x2)
easy (X3)
easy (x4)
you can do it
easy
Worst level I have ever seen in my life
"Pewdiepie's Challenge"
CHALLENGE ACCEPTED
oh
No, I made this level.
I made this shitty level
you can actually get through this bit
look I did it
Let's not play that one.
What the hell is this?
"PewDiePie is a ****?"
how
how dare you!
Oh god
Oph
my god.
It's impossible
Hey, I did it
I did it
thank you
now what
Oh god
Oh
there we go I did it
Nooo
Ohh nooo
stupid
"Bananer I Pyjamas Kart 64"
Did you guys have that show
bananas in pajamas?
bananer i pyramus
what the heck is that?
I'm raising a banana
And I can't let him win
come on
Hell Yeah
Oh God
stoppp
I can't let this stupid banana win
No
the banana has a rocket
He's cheating
oh my god
this is so dumb
I'm not gonna lose
to a banana
alright
I'll lose to jacksepticeye, fine.
a banana?
Over my goddamn dead body
Did I do it?!
Of course I did it
What kind of question is that?
Excuse me Mr. Banana?
Hot dog you can...
There you go
Thank you
That was amazing
Well done Kev
Very creative
Really proud of you guys and your creativity
Make some more levels for me
And I'll play it in the next episode
if you enjoyed watching
leave a like
if you enjoyed the game check it out
It's out on Steam early access
Appreciate all the support
And as always
Stay awesome bros